[Music]
hello I'm Greg Sadler the president of
reason IO and I'm very excited to tell
you about some of the online events that
we've got coming up this month in fact
just next week dealing with Plato's
classic text the symposium one of the
greatest works in Western literature
we're gonna be focusing on the key
themes of love sex and politics we have
first a free online webinar 45 minutes
long open to anybody who wants to come
in September 11th that's a Monday from
11 o'clock to 11:45 again that's a free
event anybody can sign up for it then
later on that week that Saturday
September 16th we're going to have to
much longer to our intensive online
seminars capped at 12 participants each
and those will air at 10 o'clock a.m.
and 4 o'clock p.m. so that we can get
everybody in who wants to have a seat
all of these are central times so make
sure to check your time zone the the
webinar is open to anybody come with
questions because I will be taking 20
minutes of Q&A after doing about 25
minutes of presentation in the much
longer intensive seminars we break it up
we look at some some text and discuss it
some of the themes then we do some Q&A
then we do some more then more Q&A and
everybody gets a chance to ask all the
questions that they want sometimes these
go a little bit longer great ways to
learn about this this wonderful text is
one that I have been reading and
teaching for about 20 years in part
because it's such a great work I can't
put it down so if you're interested in
Plato particularly in Plato's symposium
these are things you want to mark a new
calendar hope to see you there
[Music]